yeah welcome back buddy thanks buddy
Monday Monday morning Monday mug yeah
good morning ready 19 for you
typical routine eggs wait no no no fresh
dicks uh no why no no don't do any of
that in the morning eggs coffee rub [ __ ]
nope nope nope nope I wake up I get
myself I get myself some coffee just
kidding I don't drink coffee right now
that's Cathy and I'll have some green
tea caffeine apparently can sometimes
affect your surprise now now now I have
some green tea you what can I just
notify you going to notify the listeners
that you're wearing braces I'm having
I'm why if it sounds like he's dr.
headlights raised in I have my trade
here hey everybody don't buy one of me a
1 years old no I got braces
the next thing coming up it's a yellow
or black I don't dunk girlfriend this is
not very accomplished Kevin Africa it's
not fair I saw bring through Invisalign
right now I'm wearing my trays do we
have two weeks 14 weeks and I will wear
them 20 hours that's not one ton I don't
know half a year does it 14 weeks that's
a long time alright anyways Karen so
you're getting your dream wake up I get
in the Sun I get in the Sun got a Sun
the body's gotta get some UVB rays I am
out there I'm out there all spotted like
a big old [ __ ] man leopard in your
undies I mean I'm on these because I
don't have any of it around my ass or
I'm a pubic area you don't have any nuts
in you Derek it's spelled out that
spares that area I don't know why Wow
and my ass is pristine but the thighs
the calves the shins and dude the old
top of the feet you saw him a feet he
said let me send me a picture it means
picture your feet that was the worst
foot I've ever seen my life I've been
the worst foot of all time ever
yep it looks like a new guys were none
too kind you guys were none too kind
with all the things you were saying
about me I mean Brennan and Chris Lea I
mean you think your friends be like dude
man then you'll get over this man just
to apply that cream none too kind
you disgusting
a to the foot a thousand things you said
not so uncool so uncool
and after I then I get into some dinner
then I've done a soak in my epson salts
soak in my epson salt got a soak your
absence what a hassle then a dry off and
I apply my talent X which is my vitamin
D cream and some other thing that's in
it that we're all over Malawi works like
a [ __ ] by the way really works
very well I apply that apply that oil
all over my body but torso of death
harms your legs
I have not had I'm not touched my back I
can't reach my back so my back will stay
a little bumpy for a while now listen
where's wifey she's to touch you she's
out of town so I got that going then
then I go get my green juice getting the
green juice they say to drink games
drink a shitload of green juice but I
got to tell you it's all working do you
have to live like this release your life
no it's all working and I'm tell you
right now and be be psoriasis free about
you never to money free doctor you say
bro in my life always looming you behind
you if you have one bad night with wine
cheese yeah and then no sleeve can't do
it stress yeah it's bad I'll tell you
something else oh I got something else
to say to everybody by the way you know
what makes me feel [ __ ] really good
eating mostly vegetables and low-fat
foods
I don't care of Isis well like I was
eating just a lot of eggs and a lot of
[ __ ] ground beef and just fat
saturated I joseffer so I have trouble
with it brother I do so well with just
fish maybe a little lean chicken and
vegetables and then some in the morning
some steel-cut oatmeal some flax seed
powder some [ __ ] walnuts and I'm good
feel nice yeah I feel Cheetos not
feeling really good yeah there's a lot
of grease a lot of fat I don't do well
with it and I talked to Andy Gavin as
his PhD in physiology studies what he
trains a lot of great athletes and stuff
did a podcast with him actually and he
drops today and he he he's a really
smart guy and he said everybody's body
is different some guys that's all I
always say you say so he says I'm do do
really well with saturated fat
some people don't that's when people are
pushing do this or try this it's like
man it doesn't it doesn't work for the
masses it might work for you might not
right yeah you say that all the time you
know what works for you you said that
somebody who made slot since you went do
you feel good yeah well then keep doing
it keep on keepin on man yeah yeah
what do you've done all the diets well
is there anything that you subscribe to
my stuck taquito the hardest paleo is
pretty easy
I like paleo - yeah I like paleo that's
kind of what I'm doing yeah hey a paleo
might be my favorite for longevity nuts
seeds vegetarian and I'm starting out
there work for me now I need my me yeah
if you're working I don't think about
that all meat that you the carnivore
diet I think it's crazy
oh I don't I'm sorry do I look do I look
like an alligator yeah do I look like I
just consume meat
I think it's retire I'm sorry I'm I'm
lying yeah no honey my greens
nema grains so so the Bantu belt of
Africa like in in like Kenya and that
whole area all the way down said I
forgot the bond - about a lot of the
people other tribes like the Masai
people make it and get it twisted
they do live primarily on a carnivore
diet however they're also living with
their their their cows and their sheep
not even having them drive there they're
drinking the blood and they're drinking
the milk there's a suckin there - yes
they drink the milk they drink have you
everyone wanted that no without a suck
on those tits you have of the cow udders
tits yeah under the cows okay well how
about this first of all you doesn't
squeeze it into your mouth
apparently it's warm I don't want to but
my dad my dad did the dad did in
Wisconsin when he's young but Dad dear
apparently madad madad madad sucked on
smothers you death of Leto
yeah yeah he apparently he grabbed that
other and I do want to do farmers do
that a lot
oh I've always wanted a blade boy it's
the least they did I've always had I
like you I've always had a need to
squeeze an udder
I wanna I sort of it is it's all hug
honors there's no bad very quick utter
story for you I'm in Mexico this last
time and I'm chewing on this food and
I'm like I don't know man this meat
super chewy it was utter meat oh yeah
they serve this and he said other and I
said it's it's seitan it's not real meat
and she goes I don't think so
and then we got the egos it's the utter
of the count you're of that canelo diner
dude this is that a nice restored I was
like hey guys how about not cutting
corners and feeding me [ __ ] to honor
who the other top you'll say not to
prisoners or anybody a life it tastes
like rubber it sure did it tastes
exactly what you would think it tastes
like [ __ ] red like chopped up rubber hey
amen ha is this good your tires have you
sucked off a cow like that though no but
I will
- I don't know and if you look at them
it's all juicy yep it looks soft it it
looks soft your Papa's blasted that in
his mouth huh I think so
don't say blasted don't say that about
my father don't say your Papa's blast
and in his mouth it's because don't ever
say that again
okay don't say your bus blast you know
how I would in my shows this weekend one
love everybody one love I know I wash
that what hundred times I was when I see
your face cut when here you go what
would you turn to it and I was dead
serious you know so I got excited it's
so great what do they do with cow udders
let's take a look you can cook them yeah
yeah I mean I'm not eating it and I not
even should
I'm not eating animal tit oh why would
you eat that
because you eat everything yeah it's not
good poor cows I know look at that
let's just go Mooka it's in a body
building for him it's 690 you know but
of course bodybuilders well it was like
that's like my buddies my buddies I get
to my house in Venice I had this huge
picnic table I'm not my two buddies who
are morons have bison balls bison
testicles they're cutting them open and
they're eating them raw with lemon
because they they were like it ah strong
that's like he's a bodybuilder
like man you know there's the the
nutrients and the HGH in women's breast
milk I think is crazy
so guy started buying women's breast
maja out of the igf-1 and well if that's
why I got idea or just Jack yourself
with steroids and eat the meat
well it's called colostrum yeah so so so
a lot of um a lot of times we get like
sheep colostrum cow colostrum my our
friend is a little bit kooky she had an
eye infection and when my wife was
pregnant she called me six times so she
can borrow some breast milk do you do a
man a squirt or tan and she didn't
squirt it in her eyes she gave her some
milk and then she squirted it into her
eye because she said it had healing
properties and she said it also just get
some drops from the yeah also get some
photos don't rub Amanda's titties in
your feet don't call don't call for my
my wife you're taking milk out of my
child's mouth no you can't have it for
your gross haha what she she was in her
family too old simply too old no you
can't have it for your gross I it
belongs to my child Tommy
dude I was watching a American Idol last
night and I felt like saying one love to
they're showing this story of this guy
from the Congo and he's homeless and he
came to America and he found this white
wife and then they had a kid and he
needs to go home this white and then
they took then his two brothers who were
basically like starving he flew them out
somehow they got out to LA he took him
under his wing and he's like I'm just
trying making life for them and dude you
know I was getting choked up glass where
this one guy suffered so bounds adopted
didn't those parents and his mom died
and he was singing a song for her oh
dude that's a good joke right love I
don't make you cry and love yep Jenny
you noticing that I have my trace in
probably not right I didn't notice at
all thank you oppression if Jin does
know details though but there now I have
like a million things going on here so
you watch oh oh yeah first thing he goes
braces your period
braces are back Razorback where'd you
get it done
I'd start all over again when'd you get
it done um I don't know like Thursday a
lot of fun where are you going this
weekend
but at this week Breckenridge doing some
skiing since q yeah don't like skiing
out there just you want to play boat oh
yeah Sonny Bono's three died yep here's
a drink rich people die all the time
yeah yeah because not all the time it's
kind of ridiculous
they died 24/7 when they ski dude I uh I
was super bummed out it [ __ ] me out
you know sometime like we told about
your your nephews friend dying in Mexico
getting caught by the cartel and and
tortured that bothered me yeah and then
another thing bothered me was in San
Jose Jay and I were walking around and
there's this mom this she was that she
could tell she was Indian you know she's
Indian Native American no no or Indian
Indian yeah and she was she was kind of
young and she had two kids one maybe
Tigers age another one younger she was
homeless sitting on the ground that's
[ __ ] me up all day
yep all day yeah and I went in you know
I am you know buying a sweater it's
whatever $100 the conex just give her
that money so I went to the ATM and gave
her some money start crying good for you
and I thought god I wonder if that's a
hustle that's the problem is that reals
that I don't know and you know in in
Buster's culture in Thailand or in
Buddhism they think you know you did
something wrong in life and your look
down upon you know I'm saying I know I
know
well like why are you giving her money
like uh I have a son who's - yeah no hos
she's out there in the corner of the
street it's 85 degrees out right now and
she's sitting down there with a
two-year-old if you're hustling if
you're hustling me great cuz guess what
you're sitting on the street with your
two kids it's a good hustle yeah I don't
care that you're hustling me in that
situation it's like you're working for
your money and when we're not it bummed
me out man yeah that bummed me out like
this
yeah I don't want to pick this up ever
podcast I grew up around that so much as
a kid you're used to it I'm not you
never used to if you want I can go get a
job grouch I'm like come on no as a kid
oh that's all I saw went in the
developing world with kiddos you just
see children come to your there they beg
them
India and Pakistan back in the day and a
lot of place and yeah don't Buddhist
think like you did something your riccar
nated like you're a lower class yeah
well so so in the right
the idea the idea of of a higher birth
versus a lower birth and the Indian
caste system the Hindu system has
something a little bit similar right and
the idea in fact really the British in
England the great chain of being was the
same way you were born into a certain
status and you stayed there and it was
your lot and like did your duty
according that a lot India had a very
strong caste system do you know what
that is they had the Brahmin at the top
which was the priest class yeah and then
all the way on the bottom they had what
was called essentially the untouchables
and they did all the dirty work they
would clean latrines and they would do
things like that like the cool
untouchable when you obtain yes and you
never ever saw an untouchable ever marry
a Brahmin I mean it was never laid on
and there was a status there was
literally just a status you know in fact
Hitler Hitler's Third Reich they what
his will debase them yeah well he wanted
to create a society that was based
essentially on the Indian caste system
illegally and on and on loosely and on
Plato's Republic
both of which had this notion that there
are philosopher kings at the top the
guys who actually designed society and
have all the knowledge he'll and then
people that do you know then you have
the lid the lower clod the aristocracy
the landed gentry nobility and you know
the peasant class and all that stuff
right and then your slaves crazy
there was always slaves intouchables
were a form of slave and there was
always that and societies have always
done that and it's very recent very
recent that we have something called the
Bill of Rights and the Declaration of
Independence where all men are created
equal that's a radical idea we were
talking about out fear I was talking
this comic in LA and you know things
aren't going great for me goes you know
I'm Anna I'm not like you guys I can't
kiss ass what excuse me yeah yeah you
know I just can't do I can't kiss ass my
god that's just the wrong mindset mine
is the wrong good god you should kiss
ass we at you and I are talking about
that I would talk but when I got into
this business I might have sucked your
dick just for a small part and I would
have been happy to do it
and this idea that I don't compromise
myself well I get it I get not you know
having sex for money I'm talking about
do whatever it takes that's because you
want
that bad you're not touchable be a
[ __ ] untouchable clean I like rule
Italian my feelin touch like [ __ ] the
Train if you have to to get yourself to
the next like that [ __ ] with your
tongue and clean that [ __ ] er well clean
it well do the best job you can and I
swear to God with that mindset you'll
take it to the next yeah but you're
saying you're not saying arms shouldn't
kiss ass hopefully give me a part you're
saying because you want it the dream so
bad you're willing to do what it takes
[ __ ] right god damn right there no
excuses are there any excuses are there
at the end of the day I mean I'm saying
your whole family died in the fire it's
terrible but the but but you don't stop
moving no your competition goes terrible
but I'm I got a pay bill too
he's not here today Oh me I'll go yep
that's all that's just how it is
yep I'm sorry that things did I you know
it doesn't matter if there are no
excuses it they and of course their
excuses there aren't none and you if you
look back like then Madonna was eating
trash some [ __ ] like that there's a
story about and I've heard this these
are the stories I would always read
about people that really made it and
before they made it the kind of hunger
Quincy Jones where he came out of he
talks about like that you know Madonna
like like literally where they were so
hungry Billie Holiday Billie Holiday
holy [ __ ] I mean you're talking about
people who said they said what drove you
said hunger but real hunger the fact
that she was 13 years old her
grandmother in Harlem was gonna be
kicked out onto the street in the middle
of the winter and there was no net man
no and that's what she went to every bar
she went to every bar at 13 years old
cause she used to clean houses with her
Rambler her mother she went to every bar
and sang and at the end of the day she
picked up 37 dollars back then because
her boy said people were crying in their
beers and that's what how she saved her
grandmother for being on the street in
the middle of the winter in Harlem in
New York City New York City if you never
been in the winter there it is it'll
hurt your face it's so cold you can't be
out there you'll die yeah okay and it
was ID or grandmother or her mother
either way that Billie Holiday
I watched the finish the Garry Shandling
document out did I want to see that if
you're in the comedy or if you're a
comic it actually shows kind of the
process and how articulate he was
and kind of how he got to where he was
at but never in this depth and with his
journals and stuff like that again if
you're a comical guy Judd Apatow is one
of the only people I know who really can
articulate it and put it on paper in his
book you know sick in the head or
through this Garry Shandling documentary
but there's a part in the Garry
Shandling documentary I'm glad I was
alone and I was watching my brothers HBO
Go on-demand thing and they left to get
some DEET I'm glad they were gone
because I was dude really Sonique a
motional oh my god cuz it's time out so
his brother passed away he was like 13
years his best friend passed away and
his family didn't deal with emotions he
even didn't tell me about his brother's
funeral he mr. brother's funeral no one
told me his brother died they're just
like oh he's sick the next day his
brother's gone he's like what the [ __ ]
and they were best friends so that kind
of [ __ ] them up and then um you know
he was on this pursuit and he was he was
riding a ton they have all his journals
he done he he would journal everything
man that's right non-stop but not jokes
just his life and he was doing all this
stuff and so you know he started doing
some comedy and they go the comedy story
talked about how the comedy store and I
always loved the old-school comedy store
stuff you know I love I can't get enough
of that you seen how he was there and
there was you know all these all these
guys and he goes it felt like high
school where there's a cool kids club
and then you know if you're not part of
that Club you're you know you're good
but you're not really invited to goes
I'm not gonna let this define me so he's
one of the first kind of well known guys
start going elsewhere he'd build a magic
club in Hermosa and start going all over
he's like I'm not just gonna stay here
like you guys I'm gonna go all over this
doesn't define me and he's saying how
who was it
George Carlin George Carlin when he was
20 or one of the best of all and best of
all time when he was I think Garry
Shandling was 21 he saw that George
Carlin was doing a set in Arizona so he
drove for hours and had jokes had a
bunch of jokes on paper and after George
Carlin's set went up goes hey man I want
to do comedy what do you think of this
and George Kontos come back tomorrow
same time and he goes like alright Satan
he's like there's no way he's gonna look
at he's gonna tell me that like some
[ __ ] he goes there and he walks in
and George Carlin on the table in the
back and the
in the green room you know back there
has all of his papers and there's marks
and notes all over it and he was there's
some funny stuff in here your green
there's funny stuff in here you can do
this and he said that was literally all
he needed to get going all you need he
gone but so he's doing count he's doing
well he's going on The Tonight Show with
Johnny Carson he kills it he kills it
right and his his number one goal and he
said everyone around the economy store
was just have five minutes just have
five [ __ ] minutes man get five
minutes so he can get on tonight's show
and so he's just been working on his
five minutes he gets up then literally
destroys like never before and Johnny
Carson goes man it's that's a spent
literally goes that's the special one
and he says he walks off and Bob Saget's
in the back I know they were this close
Bob Saget was in the back and because it
was Shandling's dream for Everett since
he was a kid to get on tonight's show he
never thought past that
so he gets done he absolutely kills it
and falls into Bob Saget's arms and
starts crying cuz it was done he thought
that was the answer and he didn't know
what to do I've always wanted this and
now it's here I crushed it and this was
my goal I don't know what to do and back
then like a shadow that if when you
crushed on Johnny Carson you everybody
in America Oh everybody America
reference that so Freddie Prinze who's
Freddie Prinze Jews dad
Freddie Prinze who's 22 when he passed
away but Freddie Prinze much before went
on there crushed it two days later had
his own show just from that two days
there got offered his oh so and I was
talking to the comics in San Jose I went
man there's nothing like that now is
there like you can't go on not a
concentrated there's not a guy's not
concentrated right if you want to spread
out over all this stuff like yes you
can't there's no Johnny Carson going
there's no if you if you go on Jimmy
Kimmel right now and you do you five
minutes make make a difference Wow
you use it the streets tomorrow and I
can do I can do a lot of those shows and
it doesn't make a difference it would be
a four minute five minutes set and then
I guess it would get you more Twitter
followers or something but that's it
it's not but I was thinking like it's
it's kind of it's good and bad because
back then you know if that was your goal
and you did it not the part your
instance yes yes now you have more
resources you can get up more places you
can go on podcast yeah yeah I just it's
it's it was very it was
a few people in show business had a
shitload of power to expose you there's
like five though here your chances of
breaking yeah not if you were on a
sitcom on NBC or ABC or whatever Robin
Williams you you were you were a
household name you were here I worried
when you flew over Los Angeles or New
York everywhere there was a light they
knew your name it's just I like that is
now so much content there's so much it's
good I'm back because more people have
access to jobs and more people are
famous but at the same time it's just
it's not the same sort of fame is it
I'll say something what it did to was
when you were famous when you did make
it in that crop diffident were oh you
were so good you know Ed Asner we should
actually think about it you know ed as
nervous I'll bring him up finally a7m
he's won seven Emmys he was on The Mary
Tyler Moore Show he was a star all the
way through the one of the greatest he's
80 he's 90 he still sharp his attack
yeah it'd be fun to have him on to talk
he would did a movie of Elvis old
Hollywood we should have he's the
greatest I'd love that he's the greatest
[ __ ] he's an incredible incredible
actor still doing it still doing it with
Mary Tyler Moore right there he's a
legend he's a Hollywood acting legend
Jonathan sorry Garry Shandling was
talking about how back then it was I
sing about the comedy store it was like
Letterman it was Andy Kaufman it was the
I'm Jay Leno it was just the haters
haters back at ran you know what say
something you're in pretty good company
today in other words those great guys
were great yeah you know what but you're
you're with you're with people that can
hold their all for sure
you are among right now I don't enjoy
that we can go through the bill burr
yeah you know Tom Segura Daniel Tosh
you know everything you're in very good
Halloran though man you know Joel I was
thinking about that when I was when I
was actually on the plane yesterday I
was thinking about I said man when I'm
older and guys passed away and things go
on because I'm so intrigued with the
history of the Comedy Store and
Hollywood I said man I bet when I'm
older than Tigers older he's gonna ask
about the days of the comedy store
because there's more good comics now
there
yeah then there were bad
then yeah because x is by the legend
grows of each guy and I think about the
comics there now and II Jeselnik have
you seen him no he's on me he's a man
well that guy I mean you know that guy
so unique and I mean you'll get his dry
humor I watch the other night I'd never
seen him and I was like this guy's I
watch she's unbelievable i watch Daniel
Tosh is special and he's unbelievable
you wanna talk about a monster he's so
funny
you know I love music why I'm too famous
that why would I do he doesn't give a
[ __ ] I love I love Tosh he's so he's so
irreverently so not fake he does not
I've seen him in very awkward situations
where he doesn't like somebody and he
lets them know really right then in
there I'll tell you a story is so funny
Larry he's he's so funny and in my
opinion again you know been doing this a
long time what got him to the dance the
comedy that got him to the dance maybe
the top top three years for me top five
in his new stuff [ __ ] I haven't seen
new stuff but he's a beast
he's a [ __ ] he's so good he's as good as
it gets and it'll get better than stuff
on tosh point-o it's there no one tenth
season somebody just renewed it yep yep
yeah he's incredible and surfs lives him
lives out in Malibu surfs and does
stand-up and his show mm-hmm yeah but
that Garry Shandling dock man oh when
that when their time out where and and
Bob Saget starts to tear up and he goes
the other through his dream he's always
wanted this was his highest aspirations
and then he did it and he everyone's
cheering and he looks at Bob Saget who
was his best friend goes oh my god but
not like yes we're here like oh [ __ ]
I did it it's over and then like what
what I have no where'd I go what the
[ __ ] do I do now and falls into Bob
Saget's arms search crying dude I'm
telling you I'm glad no one's in the
room I know I know a couple bills
including Piven who was on a show but I
know a couple of wrote on all of the
Larry Sanders show yeah oh yeah my buddy
ed Solomon yeah joe yeah Piven was on
there yeah Solomon who wrote on the show
and
broke his cherry with Gary Gary gave him
his first job and this is what's
instrumental Gary and I'm sorry I'd went
on to write men and black and all this
yeah this what's interesting about Gary
Shandling and Rogan has these traits and
I mean you do a lot of successful people
that shouldn't say a lot but he was a
guy if you look at how many people's
lives he touch where it's so easy to be
in his position like a [ __ ] you man your
competition so much you're young and
upcoming now Elmo pay your dues
he helps so many people it read look up
whoo it's the six degrees of separation
with Gary Shandling
it's nuts yeah but I feel like that's
the mentality you want where this they
think so I think it's so important I've
always lived my life that way I just I
believe you should help people I you can
do it yeah if somebody's worth it yeah
you know when I when I help somebody and
they I'll get a text sometimes you know
thank you
i I always answer the same way you're
worth it yeah if you're worth it if I
see hustle yeah you and I used to say
you don't have same way if I cease
hunger and I see hustle um I'm there for
you I'm there for oh dude you would have
loved yeah click on that yeah oh that's
a movie 62 separation with Will Smith um
but you would have loved at a San Jose
show I talked about him below the belt
but you can definitely correlate to you
but but my opener the MC what was his
name
asam Hassan Jomon the son the door guy
at the Comedy Store they are not nice Oh
check this out he has a NASA hat on
right then he always wears a hat cuz
loosens here and he's a he's 24 he's a
NASA hat on and we're talking I'm like
god that hat looks legit is [ __ ] so
you want me I'm into fashion like I had
it that it's [ __ ] sick
I would you get that hat man like banana
but with some [ __ ] we did that hat
here's oh my dad's a rocket scientist
for NASA ha ha my dad works janessa I
like really goes yeah and I'm like
what's it you know I was intriguingly
what do you do he goes oh actually right
now he's working on a silent helicopter
and he's trying to figure out the
neurons in the air I'm like oh my god so
he I go he's this parents are from San
Jose so that's why he's up there so he
that's us at the far right there so he
that's awesome so he goes oh my dad
makes the best barbecue in the world I
went way works for NASA everything he
does is great I'm sure
and he goes if there's leftovers I'll
bring it to you I'm like police do so
the next night the Friday not about the
show he brings the barbecue and he goes
hate my dad once you have this barbecue
you know appreciate you having me open
for know probably this but they need
they want to meet you
like really bring him up side me don't
talk to my Kate that's not flat right
and he just starts by me laughing at me
all these rights yeah so what's in true
what's crazy about the Pakistani or
Indian or Iranian in Indian and his dad
grew up on straight streets Oh
NASA rocket scientists so it's amazing
story but that a son his parents want
him to be a doctor so it's years to San
Diego 4.0 everything but he needed he
had to have take one class to go to
pre-med school but he want to be a comic
so what he did is he delay taking that
class cuz he knew it give him at least a
yearly ready to try comedy yeah so he
told parents no I just I didn't get in
so I have this year off you know what
the only he's doing he's doing comedy
and finally eventually tolds parents
doing comedy they came to the show and
said there are certain immigrant groups
like Indians like Pakistanis in this
country like I mean so many different
like Nigerians like IBAs and like
different kinds of groups ethnic Chinese
Koreans where you you in this country
you're gonna get three degrees and
you're gonna learn an instrument and
you're gonna be you know I mean it's the
pressure to be a high performing
individual those cultures well what
their own ascent through to get yeah you
don't drop all culture of discipline and
hard work it's in credits funny to men
yeah I told his dad I went man I go all
around the country I've MCS that
features I'm telling you think can do
this yeah and I know he's a complete
disappointment to you well Fahim who's
from Afghanistan he's he's a funny a
[ __ ] you seen for him at the Comedy
Store
bring him up oh my god my cameras last
thing he sees Afghani okay um he was a
rocket scientist he did work for NASA
Fahim Anwar he I think
he has his master's in chemical
engineering I believe oh my god is he
fine smoke writing for them was like oh
no he's for real he's for real and funny
as [ __ ] if I him killed me the other day
I was watching him but he's great he's
great he started to well I'm so happy
for him we got to get him on the podcast
actually aerospace engineer at Boeing oh
wait you know what let me stress comedy
yeah and and crushes and crushes I love
it man yeah in fact I saw him the other
day I called him up I got his number I
go hey bro I'm older you know I was like
what are you doing cuz you're really
funny are you what's going on I want to
make sure you're you know people are
seen yeah yeah because a lot of times
young guys get a little bit would you
say he's dude he's doing he's doing the
job Mase doing how young is doing a
thing probably 30 I don't know something
how old is he hmm watch him be 56 oh gee
he has adèle-elise a to the drug row 34
Oh Sara Lee's getting over [ __ ] they
made oh my study first do we just come
best friends for him yeah when's your
birthday
March 18th oh they'll meet him look
similar yeah you did looks like my
brother yep much smaller smarter brother
yep I'm psyched to see him kicking ass
dude speaking of brothers my brother ate
that rock scientist barbecue and farted
in the greenroom did he really
and it I swear ting the guy came he goes
oh my god and Jay goes who opened the
grave oh right I go do you have a fan or
something kids without talking it was
like some dead person opened their mouth
and he just was writing for you it was
so work Sambi breath oh dude and I
looked at it's the only time I got mad
at Jellicoe it he's [ __ ] me what's
wrong with you well we all have to hang
out here he goes I don't feel good well
alright you know out San Jose is he
opens up all the windows yeah and he's
taking the Phantom on home on who's the
manager he's out there anymore he's gone
there's a new guy oh I think there's new
guys there's new guy who's amazing from
England it's great that's a great
theater you guys a new guy from England
God don't kill me Derek I think that's
it's not a club it's a theater yeah
that's a that's a mini theater that's a
mini theatre to me theater and not so
many either it's it's that's a little
bit Youth improv yeah yeah your boy did
saw two shows though I don't know if you
guys have seen let's just switch gears a
little bit speaking of performances have
you seen them
well let's just take a look at this for
a sec guys because the more thing yeah
what's that they're more singing no have
you seen Brock oh the gay sir bring up
Rocco the gays that's only a porno sir
oh you might want to take a look at
Brock oh the gazer 60-second doc yeah
this is Braco with a dual gazing music
why'd you go ahead and uh well do the
60-second doc actually go I mean you let
me see this tune though well I wish your
boy want to ruin it yet I want you to
pause it
yeah pause it go to the other one leave
that to rock with the Gator right there
go ahead let's just so he doesn't speak
the cases more than 7000 people come to
one single event to meet Russell because
they feel something through brother's
case I work in in practice severe can
get with this gays in front of groups of
people they feel [ __ ] off do these
people crying feel like life makes how
greatest oh my god say that it is
life-changing for them even scientists
have researched the power of his case
but still they don't know right can a
good days it's a good day so he's a
charlatan but that's a good day he's a
charlatan but hooray I'm buying this
look at him bro he looks friendly as
[ __ ] I want to cry and look at this so
friendly so he just gets up there and
stares at Allah and they stare back haha
bro let's go to this wait their
celebrity get him I just saw I saw Naomi
no Naomi Watts no Naomi I know the mom
nohe Campbell yeah I just saw her in
that and Tom Brady yep dude that's
brocco David oh no - eat some bread
that's brocco huh hey good is a music
7,000 tickets bro huh that's how many
tickets he's selling he should
he's making a fortune oh he goes oh you
guys doing our jokes hilarious he's
making this yeah making a hundred grand
every time he goes you know what though
that's a good gaze it's a good gaze and
it's [ __ ] cheesy and was he in LA
wait good look at that a meal I'll buy a
ticket to this I bet you it's oh I bet
you can't savagely start this dude you
know what he's yet dude I'll go to this
and a hearty two and sell people [ __ ]
cuz it's just a room for suckers let's
take advantage of his [ __ ] audience
he's in Germany
oh he's in Germany let me go go back to
video Jews here dude he's packing house
he goes he always had to have seagulls
but does he not talk at all mo sure
doesn't ever
he's the gazer bro here on how to talk
dude down he doesn't because when he's
backstage he goes we got them on guys
all right divvy it up divvy up you from
Sylvania the hot ones get on your knees
thank you
I feel like grunting a little bit look
at him great body I've got those wide
hips narrow shoulders and long dear it
just solid gazed them he's walking
through the woods of course and just
kind of look what a [ __ ] business
plan it's a beautiful business plan it's
it's it's genius like waterfalls and
look at these structures all these
people look at that group of suckers let
me ask you this though there's any
flowers dude let me ask this me this is
any different than celebrating Jesus
Christ of course it is because at least
Jesus person yeah but this is a
philosophy Jesus spoke he had some
radical ideas love yeah I mean what'd he
say turn the other cheek yeah you say
that yeah it's on my phone Wehling show
me the dock that he says you don't know
it's called the Bible if you want to go
to hell keep denying it the point is it
I'm just saying isn't visible its
present it's pretty incredible dude look
how many people are [ __ ] keys in this
man's eye look at that look at that he's
just had two solid days oh why I bleed
that's some [ __ ] also he's got it
how are you show though
it's video how long this show um I don't
know but too long I can guarantee it's
sim how'd you find out about this guy
look at him here how do you decide what
to wear
he just gets up there and stares at you
like he's bombing look at the women
crying oh you know what you have to be
there dudes
look at these guys look at these [ __ ]
wives selfie Wow I call them useful
idiots dude look at this power of silent
I want to go take advantage of them and
sell I want to sell shell out okay let's
sell magic water let's sell healing
water oh look at these tell me well I
guess good this guy was smart by ex-mo
type man oh man look at this guy that's
Armand de Sade that's the actor I love
him amazing actor you still gonna hate
on this man's gaze yeah I am but
Hollywood anytime holly was into
something you know you know was his New
York show we were born so oh look at him
here powerful scarf dude you know what
chin is there no video and then I own
the camel dude that's neon camel that's
it I'm a camel she's a beautiful woman
well Google after this she said sit on
me [ __ ] apparently so and look at her do
that go from yet she's great yeah what
is she doing with him uh changing lives
all right she's crying actresses and
actors
who's that [ __ ] an actor too if you
can't be my friend I wish my picture was
in on this that's Stella McCartney
anything
Oh bono cry don't cry he's just staring
don't you just so powerful in person
they'll be maybe he's life-changing yeah
yeah nah nah let me see look at her it's
just people lost they want to be told
what to believe and say what is this
done probably Twitter followers to dev I
don't know probably not a big Twitter
guy but maybe he is reaching the hearts
through silence
god what a side hustle it's a great side
out song
oh okay well here's for $700 got your
fake if it says feel the gays feel no
ready I'm not seeing gays feel the gays
gee a drunken comfort can be found in
the warm familiarity that's his real
white hunter type opens up your heart
and enlivens hope once again feel the
warmth tape down gaze on in drink it in
Brian cut to him in five years being
arrested for tax evasion and fraud had a
fall I thought you know I'll give him
that though it's a solid case it is a
solid case can you give me your best
gaze me yeah I mean I mean if you want
me to open it up yeah
are you serious dad says it's not bad
that's all serial killer where's the
camera do it to the camera J's it up
Doug you have to just do this at your
next show
nope not the same as the gays it's just
not close I just cuz I had so much
wickedness and dirty look so kind well
he has such an open kind pure heart I'd
like to see what his heart looks exactly
they looked at his heart on an x-ray and
it looks like two folded doves yeah I
wonder I would like to see a baby
picture has he always looked like this
I'm sure he wasn't a baby I think he
might don't think he was ever a baby
what a stud how much money think he
makes you wait wait there he is back in
the day that's important with his open
shirt he's fantastic
well first of all he's from Romania or
Albania he was a gangster for a while
and now he is look at him he was playboy
Johnny but what I want to know is how
would they like do you we can make money
doing this just stare and don't say
anything well he found his way he
softened his look at his eyebrows he's
has eyebrows done first dude he was a
virile [ __ ] back in the day not a
good-looking guy but he thought he was
and sometimes when you will yourself to
be virile uh you know what I'm saying
there are girls will be like oh he's
just penetrating he's a beast though
yeah he's a liar yeah do you see a
little bit of Bill Murray in him I do
Murray I'm glad you said that because I
was trying to hurry
look I'm 100% see Bill Murray and you
got to see a little bit of it I don't
see journey to Braco
stories of transformation in America I
don't see Bill Murray well charlatan
he is a charlatan I love it I love it I
love how I can't believe it how do you
have to find here B yeah you went to one
tailpiece hundred watts sent it to me
good I'd like to get that guy out of
weed get him on the podcast and I would
just be really quiet oh wait no just
[ __ ] out of them no back down yep and
then we then we give him a little we
give him a little once over a little
rough up a little rough house Sunday
just so we hear and make noise
now his bodyguards a roadie depends yeah
they're probably like bogey
not insane use some convention yes I do
a couple Jim what you do this weekend
first of all I always forget I want to
eat Korean food again just 8c sounds
like things for friends yeah
weren't you going to San Francisco
shoppers that definitely the day this
week so you're out of town and you're
out of town yep when do you leave Tim
Thursday afternoon are they today for oh
[ __ ] I'm leaving don't know when I'll be
back cook your own tennis shoes I'm an
athlete alright I do sports well you
could make fun of me a my skateboarding
nope sure not nope
I did with class so my chorus so stupid
sprung it's so ready
don't say sprung though all right so you
just ate chin this weekend yeah and I
did like worked on some furniture for my
place putting shelves together all right
man remember just tournament yet so a
year ago someone did a sculpture of
ronaldo cristiano no I'm so bad UCB I'm
so bad I can see in the back like an
[ __ ] yeah that's the first one that
is what he did last year that's terrible
it's so bad even that one sucks all the
rights not great but it's better this
sculptress yeah you suck at your job
yeah the one on the right would be him
if he was in [ __ ] The Incredibles the
cartoon it's it's not dead on no it's
definitely better though so that says
yeah that's us to make good on that so
same with Santos sculptor named Santos
and then this piece the new one was
commissioned by I think bleacher report
so he made that he said this is what
he's here what he's really capable of
doing even though he doesn't feel like
his older piece was that bad either
ah I like the new one what you like way
better the one on the left looks like I
mean it's not him it looks like not him
at all look at that it looks like a
psycho behind a cage you just ate
yeah it looks like him if it was like if
someone did a shitty drawing like a
shame Adam's apple yeah shitty
everything's here is all messed up you
that guy should show not really nope
anymore it's a waste of iron the guy who
rides pretty good though yeah I don't
care
also this is good like that oh no I'm
sorry Ronaldo the the Joker or yeah you
know what that one on the right is
pretty solid the one that one on the
left is so [ __ ] bad handsome guy it's
not happy about it
oh dime piece a good athlete right that
was that one I worked this guy Adam my
buddy Adam he's so successful but when
he he'll make he'll pitch an idea and
then of course you you would come in and
then you say well this is my friend hmm
oh my god and then and then maybe he
would come back and say I don't even
know you hmm well it's yeah this is
crazy
so this is an Arizona two different
pilots saw saw something flying above
them one checked about thing like is
what's going on this car didn't even
I'll see it
thirty seconds later another pilot saw
it so it's a UFO a new one besides that
one brand new and a UFO so they're
talking about air traffic control right
now so he's asking traffic control was
there something that passed everybody
doesn't want you to know bastard nope so
they're joking in that second pilot
anything over you here in the next 15
miles 1095 affirmative we had an
aircraft in front of you that's 37 they
reported something passed over him and
we didn't have any targets so just let
me know if you see anything passed over
you
right off don't know what it was but at
least two three thousand feet above the
must be a father this is so conclusive
but it didn't show up on the traffic
control absolutely that's the video art
amazing this audio but you know what
Rosie I think something that was
submissive God knows about this stuff
and there's no video or nothing that's
just two tiles timeout so I'm definitely
Passover at 2,000 feet you have oh yes
sir that was weakest [ __ ] what if you
can't see it if the air traffic control
can't see it and then all you know
that's maybe Windows on these little
things know thousands of feet up no job
out on the green thing yeah yeah yeah
satellites and all right they didn't
pick it up I'm just saying
those Russians are making some pretty
cool planes there alright the next one
did you know a Starbucks and a bunch of
other coffee companies will have to put
a cancer warning label on the coffee
cups now for what I guess there's a
carcinogen that's inside these anything
that right anything that's cooked with
heat acrylamide yeah car frame an
overreach government overreach during
the process of baking or frying some
foods its produce and coffee beans where
they are roasted and is relevant and
brute brute cars government overreach
they have nothing else to do right now
it's like a better chill out
yeah shut up hey shut up
not only have anything better to do
right now [ __ ] off so we're gonna get
our cups now this might cause cancer
yeah oh come on drink coffee
sorry never have I don't know nobody its
silliest by the way coffees good that
epithets me I know something else is the
kind of upset you the chief the
president of the NC double-a he says
that paying the football players would
essentially get rid of all the other
sports in colleges because they couldn't
afford it yeah and there was also they
said that one of his arguments was you
have to pay the women as well if you pay
the men so obviously oh well you don't
have a same salary you
all wrong okay Pam what they're worth on
the market payment market value so if
the Kentucky men's basketball team is
dominating or Villanova's basketball
team is dominating you don't give the
football players the same everyone's
gonna get paid but there's gonna be
levels to this you don't need Marxism in
the [ __ ] in the marketplace it's not
gonna women are gonna get as much money
because they don't garner as much
attention sorry right in same thing with
with UConn women's basketball makes more
money than the men so the women should
make more money yes has nothing to
attract generate nothing now I guess a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I get the evil person man
evil evil person he looks rich and evil
there was a thing well you know let's
just do this one so this is about kpop
there's actually a bunch of different
k-pop groups that went over to North
Korea to perform for Kim jong-un well
that's big huge and this one in
particular
red velvet they're like super enormous
so they're super nervous cute
but they have to be scared for their
lives like nope off with their heads but
he was clapping along and everything so
this is such a huge direction in like
relations between south and north well
you know Kim Jong I think is very afraid
of mr. Donald Trump and I think there's
a silver lining and mr. Trump because I
think that Donald Trump might just be
crazy like a fox he's he's behaved
rather erratically boxes are crazy and
know the expression that's crazy like a
fox
just [ __ ] no crazy like foxes bring that
up in other words like you're crazy but
you know what you're doing word and so
he he basically is crazy like a fox here
because Kim Jong alone you know
essentially respects strength and power
and if he thinks his [ __ ] guys might
just blow them off the map because the
United Nations what did the Trump say
basically if you aim a missile at the
United States will just get rid of your
country yeah that's what he understands
that guy and now you've got john bolton
and and Pompeyo impact like under him
who have very very warlike tendencies
and they're very yeah i think you're
gonna see the north koreans come to the
negotiating tables real quick yeah and
you got to give Tom credit for it that's
good right he's not playing the game in
it now we've seen how diplomacy is work
yeah diplomacy with Obama everybody else
has worked really well within North
Koreans they [ __ ] and created an arc
a nuclear arsenal now we came out in
time for Dean Kim meet with the China
China's first time he's been overseas
ever right yep
and he went to China and now he's going
to and now I believe this there's a
scheduled meeting between south and
north yeah it's big did you see where
Russia has some new plane they know they
have some new missile yeah you see that
yeah they don't know if it's true though
but then did you see we one-up them like
oh you have that you can carry 13
nuclear bombs yeah well we have a plane
that flies so high it's undetectable and
can drop 24 nuclear missiles you don't
want to get into it one observation Kunj
don't get in a technology race with the
United States though remark it's a
little bit better at free enterprise
when there's a profit motive you got
Boeing and Raijin that's just about the
successful testing of that missile
you're talking about yeah but Americans
pulled their big fat American dick out
and was like oh that's very cool man
check out this plane de Guiche yeah
undetectable flies like up crazy high
but if they said it could blow up Texas
size of Texas in the United States I'm
sure I'm sure that Oh scary world man
mega Tom bombs gonna some terrible
things there's no question this yeah
it's a dark world out there
oh speaking of dark I knew you'd go dark
yeah this is weird man I saw that kid
I'm not gonna say his name but the kid
that did the shooting in Florida it
turns out he has a ton of fans from
young people to women and older men that
wanted fan letters they do like forums
online that because not only they're
saying shoot a lot of ass do with this
looks shut the [ __ ] up
I'm serious that's what they're saying
hold on I mean he's gonna get the
teenage kid who murdered kids 17 kids in
wounded 17 then groupies how [ __ ] up
is our nation this is not so Chris it's
not at all uncommon Ted Bundy no there's
so many of them so that I can get them
the I don't I shouldn't say I get I can
I can understand the mystery with these
serial killers and you know the
kill a few but we're talking about a
teenage boy who walks in a high school
and opened fires on students same thing
and a grown man the midnight strangler
the midnight stalker
Edward Ramirez I think Richard Ramirez
but very good-looking this kid a Ted
Bundy got Ted money I didn't kill 26
girls right I mean terrible ways a you
know did some terrible things so did
these guys always get there's a group of
women that are drawn to them well let's
go ahead and put this eighteen-year-old
down like a wildcat when I saw your
picture on television
something attracted me to you hmm your
eyes are beautiful and the freckles on
your face make you so handsome
yeah you [ __ ] they're kids I just are
there
keeps going down mm-hmm no Tex woman
reportedly sent a bizarre handwritten
love note less than a week after Cruz
gunned down 17 people I reserve the
right to care about you Nicholas
donations money yep he's got a lot of
money that's a prison commissary but the
good thing is he doesn't get access to
any of you so they said he doesn't see
it or doesn't know about it
because they have to go through all the
mail and all astana they don't want to
know about this a near her with a
brushing mustache Ted Cruz a card
featuring a cat and a photo of himself
sitting in a white 1990 Sun convertible
alike is a 1992 Nissan oh yes definitely
mentally stable huh yeah it's really
really common it's weird they did
documentary on this um I think it was
Harold Moore no that is some women
should kill this kid what else yeah he's
obviously mentally deranged do you want
to talk about that Ortega oh yes go
ahead bring it up or just Undertaker's I
didn't see it
where'd you look Jen I just heard you
and I looked on MMA forums
FFA forums I'm amazed websites what
stead of straight to the source
why websites all right so Breyer tell
you put this out just now for the
record an earth called me yesterday to
see if I would step in against khabib
since max hadn't responded yet
I said yes eventually max replied and
Damon gave him the fight fall goes
according to plan
I'll get my turn at both of them no 145
pounders should be trying to fight could
be another man all due respect to the
great max Holloway he's gonna get tossed
around like a rag doll and it's not his
fault you're talking about a different
animal and cubby was too big too strong
and just too [ __ ] I don't know fifty
five guys are too small for kabhi kabhi
era I be able win this belt who get a
super fight and he wants to fight GSP
Wow khabib should have to call out GSP
or he'll call out tyron woodley
and go up to 70 and get the belt it's a
no one wants that no it would lead it's
a tough tough fight for Woodley for
woodling nightmare yeah of course it is
if quiet
he said that fight for everyone his
training partners our guy named Luke
Rockhold and Daniel Cormier and he gives
him the what for it's a nightmare
it's a nightmare a nightmare I'm glad
brian ortega didn't get that fight yeah
uh hopefully well you know you listen if
they're offering life-changing money
alright yeah but can it might shorten
your career but alright but he's just
you know he's just too much of a man 3.9
million followers that's a lot but ya
[ __ ] heroes you're a superstar now
what about what what does he do to GSP
that's an intriguing fight I beat you so
do I yeah I don't think GSP wrestling
works on him as great as he is I bought
GSP could stay behind the jab in wide
stance but I think eventually goes to
the ground but it's amazing fight yeah
and I don't I'd be surprised if GSP took
that fight but he probably would right
so just be at a couple take that five
down money yeah
company for the gym is getting his his
moment here hopefully yeah
dirt oh yeah Bri sweat fourth times
fights fell through fourth 4th and Danni
goes never making that fight again I
don't care what happens I'm never making
up buddy yeah I bet he does though well
I mean it's so fresh I can I get his
frustration I'd be the same way but you
know it just it ain't right yeah it's
just not the gods are telling me
something no idea thumbs up it
bummer man it's such a bummer as much I
love back Highway on a six-day notice
man yeah I don't know who beats could be
about a [ __ ] 30 week no you know it's
six days you don't solve that wrestling
problem that weird Samba specialist
high-level whatever got a hope if you
were to fight a guy like Connor as these
company and comic and catch them
I'd be the hope yeah you can hope that
all you want again been rocked before
you sure has again I'm putting I'm
putting my house and all my money and
all my money on khabib against Connor
Connor doesn't want that fight I told
her does what they want that fight but
just watch what happens I don't know I
don't know I listen I I get all the myth
mythical legends and I hear vols stuff
about khabib but it hasn't transpired in
that gun yet
well best guys beat with dos Anjos and
that was you know not the DOS answers of
now those answers as seventies a
different animal before and then after
that it's Barbosa but he was he's been
so dominant it seems with all these guys
and in terms of controlling them yeah on
the ground but it's not like she's
finishing all you know don't get me
wrong he's complete badass he's a
nightmare and no one wants to fight him
I wouldn't either the scarce game you
see I'm just saying like we can't we
can't talk it's not out here's a lot of
work to do it's not it's not out of the
realm of possibility that if he tried to
stand and bang with Connor he could get
caught which he'll do yeah yeah we're
chill deal but he's a complete he's an
absolute nightmare no one wants to fight
Hey I swear it I swear it I think the
one can fight them right now give me 15
minutes
yes wear it I can fight Conor McGregor
Tony Ferguson anybody I swear I can do
it right I think what hurts him is he
had such a long way up between fight and
Miss Paul out of the fight so it's kind
of hurt his stardom you know I
personally absolutely love him because I
ladies were courting to apparently is
telling Michael Johnson quit no she's
not no you know I can I see that he's
saying stop now just stop now yeah you
don't want to hurt him no he should I
give up this is it you know I'm
this is over give up now and you get
demon Guzzi I need a shot
you mean time shot time to give up now
you know this I desert
that's him talking the data boy you know
I deserve it there's more where so you
just give up just stop there's just a
nice I love it
thank you absolute nightmare 25 a note -
yeah 25 an hour who's gonna beat him
yeah grew up I don't I don't know who
145 to 170 would beat him he might start
getting some frit 285 but outside that
if I had some problems but guys like yo
Romero but but I mean I don't know I
don't know but I will say this he's
gonna fight at 70 you know there are
guys who you know beat him standing I
think that he'd have trouble with
wonderboy standing I think that trouble
with their until standing but he's he's
also gotten really good at closing that
gap and once he call it once he touches
you know he did to Barbosa Barboza's
amazing striking probably they're
technically that striker in the world
crazy speed - right crazy speed
obviously Wonder Boy might have
something to say there but I don't look
I I look at welterweight and I don't see
one guy who would beat him there I would
leads his biggest threat and wouldn t be
a hell of a fight would be no he would
mop molly-whopped Demian Maia wrestling
wise right the maliwal think about that
think about what you're saying it's
[ __ ] crazy
Damien Milan just Darren chill big eye
you know we haven't seen we've seen
there until Nike team down he's a big
boy and then but Woodley would be a
stuffs matchup I I'd like to see the
odds on him verse would leak because
Woodley is a guy with you know
world-class wrestling different
wrestling freestyle wrestling college
wrestling a little different and
strikings let me ask you a works well
when it comes to freestyle wrestling the
the under hooks that cubby would have
Minister although hold let me just do
the sauce so so I was in San Jose where
a Ches located and Josh Thompson just
got done
who's a captain take a just got done
with practice could be I know how'd it
go and he goes oh good good and I said
you know kid what was key we could be
doing this he was wrestling oh yeah who
was arresting us
Edie Ruth ever heard of that Ruth no oh
we have a truce highlights for me so
that Ruth was all-american national
champion Penn State yeah yeah and did
not go well for head room I'll just say
it's just he was just saying it's just
it's just a different John didn't John
Fitch tell you that he was John Fitch
yeah John John Fitch was saying he
thinks could be would be GSP in his
prime bringing up Edie ruse critic
n-c-double-a chant but listen and Josh
Thomas is saying like all these NC
double-a wrestlers come through and
khabib it's just their Achilles heel
with I've seen up down his neck you
can't I was there a K and I saw a
two-time all-american NC double-a champ
cameras name huge huge I watched I mean
I watched Luke Rockhold do what he
wanted
like just do what he wanted to the guy
so in wrestling yes in wrestling well
there was it was but it was but it was
it was a submission it was it was them a
wrestling right it was it was grappling
not straight rested no no no straight
right Obama different I'm talking
they're only wrestling there's not MMA
it's just restless wrestling just
wrestling with that guy with with with
Ed Ruth Wow and Ed Ruth is a complete
badass yeah it didn't go well for I
don't there you go and he's a three-time
national champion oh my god oh my god
now the word is you know ed Bruce gets
him down but khabib gets right back to
his feet literally like this and kabhi
gets him down that's crazy
complete freak yep yes won best pack a
lunch if you are in the 45 or 55 pound
weight 45 mm mm I mean khabib stew big
for 55 70 70 says yeah he's gonna get
this belt
I mean look for a GSB or Connery's this
is smart thing for max Holloway to do
and make I don't yeah I'd have to hear
how much money they're giving them okay
if it's under 4 million I say enough
what wait laughing is the funny because
it's way under four million but I'd like
like I like how you're throwing money
around like this I'm just saying hi say
that again
I thought you said four hundred thousand
dollars so four hundred thousand
I wouldn't Russell could even hear
$4,000 huh if it's under three million
he should not do it Oh God but again
some guys did you know that's always a
guy when he's on this when he's on my
show said I'm the guy that people say oh
that's dangerous over there I run
towards it
he's like I've always been that guy yeah
yeah of course he's a fighter he's a
fighter through and through certain guys
are different because people say that
y'all fight anytime yeah and then when
that call comes I've seen it with my own
eyes I've also been on the end of that
call
hey listen short notice you got eight
days didn't they drop the name you go oh
[ __ ] not my knees messed up man I
appreciate it though yeah I wish ya next
time keep me on the list though that's
how it goes
yeah I've seen managers call their
fighters up when the UFC scrambling and
go hey we have this fight in the oh oh
definitely not no no no no no no chance
click and but these are guys you go wait
but yeah but you were talking oh wow
yeah yeah I know everyone in the media
says that until it's actually go times
fall and they call you the six day
notice to fight the skirts guy in the
UFC and and when you lose a loss is huge
on your right that's all we go
sure why not that takes a special kind
of do it isn't even in camp he's not
really necessarily no shape no kind of
duty is phenomenal love necks all the
way oh I have a lot of respect for max
all the way for sure there's some guys
who went fight could be both three year
notice you got three years we're gonna
go to Dagestan we're gonna learn all the
tricks huh no thanks but you got three
years I can convince me to his try and
convince me the fight could be even
through you Brendan listening okay yeah
so we got a fight set up for is except
it's here's good news bad news
okay now the good news is I'm giving you
three years to prepare a lot of time yes
wow that's very and the best coaching ok
back give me back in the swing of things
you're gonna spend some of your time in
Dagestan with some of the best Greco and
samba coaches in the world I would
how excited are you here's the here's
the tricky booze I'm gonna say it's bad
news it's tricky tricky it's tricky news
here I'll be chairing key part you got
three years three that's a long time you
got three years you fighting could be no
sound heard no I didn't hear me I said
you're fighting cubby Dawber I don't
even say the object that's how much that
call would go with me I didn't even get
the bit but you could be chick heavy no
yeah well you know what it's probably
smart idea but that's why my phone away
is max Holloway pound for pound right
top great right now top great crazy top
great crazy my brother how did you
pretty much it I want you guys to come
see me at the West Palm Beach improv
April 12 13 14 then I want you to go to
Boston I want you to go from Florida
Boulevard
- laughs Boston I want you to watch me
April 19 20 21 22 it doesn't matter then
April 26 27 28 I'm at the Denver Comedy
Works you come see me there and then May
5th a lot of dates
okay they've rippin off Colusa casino oh
dude love dohsa you come see me at the
Colusa casino youfox some guys in line
at San Jose loves doing the meet and
greets go go and see your gay Friday
okay Brian
you come see gay Brian Kayla Brian it's
weekend of gay where we release in the
tootsie roll how many licks does it take
to get to the to the center of the
tootsie roll how many leaks to take the
bus with me and Brian count as the big
gay old al nose drop Wednesday night
5:00 p.m. I just say I have a great time
on this podcast it's the best man how
much you're the best we never stop doing
this sure man as they don't die from
whatever rash you have I'm not how's
your tummy I'm fine okay yeah ballsy
bagging coffee all right I'll be
dropping anyways where am I Oh this
Friday I'm in Bakersfield Bakersfield
they're 22
it's left those were just my comps so
get them t5k calm I just released him uh
that sold out and then April 20th 21st
I'm in Calgary Calgary Yuk Yuk's Canada
first show just sold out they just gave
me a heads up so there's three shows
left
Friday Saturday two shows each night
once you already sold out get to get
down deep at kake.com more dates coming
they get to listen this is a fine kid
we're out